[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
welcome back everybody to the break room
uh new rockstars daily live show
bringing you the latest to nerdy news
live from the new rockstars office here
in beautiful los angeles uh the greater
los angeles area specifically
uh but uh i'm joined here to discuss uh
the fun topics of the day uh by my steam
panel mr brandon barrack oh hello
so happy to be here okay oh
very very esteemed very stoic uh the
wonderful jessica clemens hi happy to be
here oh
very nice and then uh back from a brief
hiatus tommy back home and you better
believe the one thing i can promise you
today
is that we're coming back strong we're
coming back long and we're about to get
the friction on so fellas yeah fellas
yeah
okay they're they're cheering for tom
daley yes
yeah long-lived tom dad uh today we've
got updates on thor love and thunder
mando season three
and jar jar binks news whoa he's alive
uh so stick around for all of that uh
also
um and you better believe we're gonna be
spending some time later on the
ridiculous chat redemption from last
friday folks that watch that episode
um we'll know what i'm talking about but
we'll catch everybody else up a little
bit later today
we're going back to our swear jar uh
with a twist so if you've never watched
the show before
as we uh receive super chats oh we just
got one just now thank you soulgasm uh
from us
from our our generous viewers we
appreciate everybody chatting and super
chatting uh if we hit a multiple of a
hundred dollars in the super chat it
unleashes our swear jar which allows one
of the people on the panel to unleash a
torrent of profanity okay otherwise
we're not supposed to be cursing
and if we hit 200 on the swear jar no
okay it releases an extra intense
passionate
personal level of a soulgasm a soulgasm
if you will of true uh true profane art
uh so again you won't know exactly what
that is i may not know exactly what that
is until we hit 200 and then we'll all
find out real quick camera four
i saw what you guys did on friday
you knew i wasn't going to be here and
you humiliated me
with our highest super chat day ever
because you knew
i'd be watching from afar scouring the
chats scouring the super chat knowing
pleading desperately wanting the numbers
to be low so they missed the back man
but no
you showed up and you set records and
for that i can truly say i hope you all
burn in hell hello
they got they got a lot of good things
on friday though they got us me and
brandon stole lyrics from songs from the
sony headquarters
we broke into sony it was the least we
could do wow yeah it was a musical day i
leave for one wedding my own
oh no
it's reverse though it makes the ring
becomes invisible
uh how about let's hop into the headline
uh first and foremost and this is a
super exciting one for us production on
loki season two just started today
uh we know that the whole main cast from
season one are set to return uh we don't
know anything other than production
started today hopefully we'll get a lot
of updates in the coming months so
keep tuning into the break room we'll
keep watching for new loki news um we
also
might be getting a late breaking uh
piece nope never mind ah
this is officially live
captain america has died
oh god what a terrible way to learn uh
we got a poster and a release date for
the disney plus series i am groot
um
do we have an asset for that john
we don't have the poster my god john you
had one job today wow he sits in there
doing a rubik's cube
11 hours a day we can act it out like
it's it's groot all right like bears
he's like
his arms and it's a young group young
group baby group yes yeah
it's animated he's got a cocktail for a
young dog
he's got some treat he's got he's got
some root juice you know some miracle
and we found out i think maybe there'd
been some hints at this but we got
confirmation it's going to be a series
of shorts they're all going to drop the
same day on august 10th i dropped a
series of shorts this weekend you know
what i'm saying gosh someone oh my god
someone throw him out throw him someone
do something help us
god please there's also these two little
little figures yes kind of hiding behind
a palm tree it looks like it's supposed
to be like an air freshener yeah they
look like porgs
like boards with four eyes maybe ticks
like that tiny big hero 6 or something
like that it's like it's just that
machine trying to make cuter and cuter
things the algorithms trying to make
cuter and cuter creatures yes
okay
now oh there it is john john found the
outside um
on the fly yes uh good work there thank
you john uh we regret everything bad we
ever said about you john works so hard
he does so much here i can't even
believe he found time for that
so busy now james gunn got asked on
twitter uh if the shorts were canon
and he responded that they are canon to
themselves i would think
what what does that mean that they're
consistent from short to short i don't
know because if he did say it's not then
you wouldn't watch it so you have you
have to be like some would say like it
hasn't could be put in a cannon and
launched space
maybe he hit the guardianship and he did
say they will not be part of the
guardian saga so you know we could
assume when when a character gets fully
animated that is not necessarily keeping
it canon well i mean the what if series
is considered canon but those are
different timelines different universes
right we can just say this is a group
from a different right
i think we all remember when beetlejuice
turned into an animated scene yes
declared non-canon that was a
devastating time for animation from uh
from a live-action film well they made
him they made him a fun partner to lydia
yeah not the horrifying
man trying to kill her married an
so let's not return to that crazy world
and let's learn from those lessons
i love this show yes the both the
animated videos
brandon's a big fan of the broadway
musical it's true i love the project
musical as well um okay a deadline
exclusive revealed that oscar nominee
maria bakalova who was played borett's
daughter in the great hilarious second
borat movie she's joined the mcu yes uh
she's been cast in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3.
uh undisclosed role at this point we
keep hearing boy they're adding a lot of
actors yeah and i thought they were done
filming they are so they must have
filmed them all now they're like slowly
saying like you didn't see him on set we
used to miss it we used a fake name you
know on call sheets in movies when it's
a big star that isn't announced they
just put their character's name and then
all their information but they leave
that part out so that's how you know
it's going to be someone good i would
think they couldn't do that for this
because then it gives away their
character too wow double faking yeah
probably there could be a world a maybe
she's in a post credit scene maybe this
is a harry styles type of deal yeah also
with the way these things are shot on
the volume stage right like if you might
have only been in the room with dave
batista or something like that you know
none of the other cast none of the other
production maybe they shot this months
after the rest of the crew raft you
never know wait maybe she's dave
batista's love interest confirmed oh
maybe she's taking over for dave batista
yeah lady drax ladies
um similar builds uh at last night's mtv
uh tv movie awards we got an extended
look at um jane foster's lady thor
mighty thor return um in the uh
a little clip
from the battle that we'd previously
seen a little clip from in the trailer
what we think is a battle on new asgard
um and the attempted reunion with
mjolnir um john can you roll that clip
[Music]
i love thor's like just enthusiasm
towards everything
i like
i'm so confused as to so she's more
chosen than he is for mueller you on
there well it seems like mjolnir came
back for her yes not necessarily for no
not for him and perhaps mjolnir feels a
little
jaded dated oh you got a new booth
jilted out um left at the altar i do
like there was a bunch of great things i
mean lots of comedy in that little clip
you know the way he's referring to it
like it's a lost like it's a lost puppy
or something like that or a former love
uh but then we also get to see jane do
the little uh
you know swingy swing thing with it uh
at the end so it's like not only is she
commanding mjolnir like she's using its
full faculties right like and that was
always part of the physics of thor too
right it wasn't that thor can fly it's
that he can throw his hammer hard enough
that he hangs
right it's not him just organically
taking off and stuff so that's always
like important the physics yeah that's
how mjolnir works i mean we obviously
don't see what leads up to this clip but
it's like he know
he knows mjolnir is there before he sees
it maybe or maybe in the clip before
this doesn't even see it fly by or
something like that i was trying to
track the audio it sounds like he says
here boy
[Laughter]
um
okay and this has this was spurring us
before yeah because we all watch this
clip
there's a couple things we're trying to
decipher about this clip a we were
speculating is this for sure taking
place in new asgard you pointed out i
think brandon that it looks like there's
some like
human american-esque civilians in the
background well i wouldn't call them
americans they're people they're people
first okay well but there's something
there's civilians
they look like patriots they're not
ancient norwegians
yeah if they don't have the clothes on
from asgard they just look like regular
norwegian civilians right and
you see them kind of like fighting these
monsters in the background i don't think
the normal citizens of norway are going
to like stream out to fight aliens maybe
they are but assuming they're as
guardians uh and if you checked out bq
this weekend you'd learn more about this
okay they're stronger than normal humans
and they've lived for thousands of years
so yeah they would like they're used to
fighting so they just take up arms and
fight whatever alien shows up on the
street unlike those cowardly new yorkers
running from the chitauri like a bunch
of babies
i was really hoping that this was which
it might probably very well not be i
wanted to be
party thor because he's he's he's like
in retirement he's like i don't want to
be a superhero right now and he goes off
on his ship and he's like i'm gonna
party so i was literally like oh this
might just be a party scene where the
hammer shows up like in what if you know
how like captain marvel was the one that
had to squash it what if it is mighty
thor like what if it is jane foster
being like you why aren't you cleaning
this [ __ ] up why uh why aren't you
cleaning this stuff up oh like this is a
party that got out yeah there's a party
that got out of control but if it is new
asgard i can also see that i just i just
want to make sure that it is new asgard
sure
we were speculating right so the initial
trailer for thor gave us kind of a
little bit of his character arc right
he's at a weird place in his life
there's a little bit of a he's lost a
lot of stuff there's a little bit of
mid-life crisis he's kind of going on a
journey of self he gets in shape there's
maybe some spiritual qualities he's
looking for friends whatever then at
some point we think only hinted at in
the second trailer right gore shows up
that kind of reinvigorates him gives
gives him a purpose to fight this guy
something something so we think where
does his reconnection with jane
fall in that timeline that's before we
think it's before gore shows up because
then when we're at olympus in those
later shots with zeus we think
jane and valkyrie are there with
thor right well that could be what gets
him back to asgard maybe he's sure he
maybe there's this like call that goes
out like all the guys you gotta come to
olympus we're having a meeting and
somehow thor is aware of that but like
he's not invited so he has to sneak in
that leads to that like flick right
because he snuck in but jane and
valkyrie are there and they see him and
they're like hey where have you been
we've been down on earth dealing with
this and he's like jane you look much
different because that that chef from
the trailer where he's like jane
right it looks bizarre the mask looks
like it was cg don he's not wearing that
mask two seconds before right in what we
saw here right the background looks
weirdly flat like i don't know where
that came from so that would make sense
if that happens in olympus and then he
goes back with them yeah to asgard and
that's when gore shows up and then
attacks people so yeah and that reaction
that jay reaction kind of just fit the
korg telling the story
uh trailer
structure yeah which i again i think
core telling that story i think that's
all just for the trailer i think taika
just did that in the booth
like this will help us tell this i do
too this trailer story right interesting
because because we were speculating that
like maybe that entire two third first
two thirds of the first trailer
uh with korg narrating that all might be
in the first 10 minutes of the movie
right right like does a good job of just
putting in the trailer what's the first
two acts and keeping all the third x
stuff out for as much as they can yes
now
where what do we think
has been jane's kind of journey up until
the point of this scene like how long
has she been
i have a theory on this oh okay please i
have a i have a theory you heard it here
first this is a tom exclusive oh
please just kidding
uh
this tom exclusive is brought to you by
our friends at uh whatever these things
are called again soup cans soup cans
soup cans the soup cans the only can
fit for my can uh all right so anyway i
think jane foster we know from a toy
spoiler which is always my favorite yes
when toys spoil movies uh
that jane is going to get a bad medical
diagnosis and uh
and the diagnosis is accurate but it's a
negative yes a very accurate medical
diagnosis that is sad yes so
i think part of that
after hearing that she's gonna be like
all right i'm gonna go have some fun
travel the world and take care of myself
maybe not stress myself out with my job
you know that might have been what you
know may have caused some of this
i'm gonna go out and you know kind of
live like i was dying like the country
song says go skydiving rocky mountain
hiking 2.7 seconds on a bowl named foo
mount shoe and you love deeper and you
spoke sweeter
and you gave forgiveness that you've
been denied so how does it become i hope
someday you get a chance to live like
you were dying all right people know
that song in the chat colin if you know
it uh tim mcgraw so anyway i think she
goes to new york hill's husband
that's right
star of 1883. uh so i think she goes to
new asgard as a way i actually forgot
what my theory was
she goes to do asgard as a way to kind
of like heal some old wounds and all of
a sudden the pieces of mjolnir start to
she's there like she's like yeah i know
maybe she knows some of the asgardians
from her time in asgard some people that
we don't ever see before that i was your
handmaiden when you were thor's
girlfriend and i was a cobbler making
shoes
yeah i'm just gonna say because her and
valkyrie have never shared the screen no
they don't they've in theory they
haven't met as we've seen and then they
have a then she's like so you're jane
foster
and then she's like i am she's like thor
said so much about you she's like he has
what are you his girlfriend i don't know
why natalie has a british accent
and then she has him for a little her
mom
marvel loves the girls do it better team
up they come together they roast the
[ __ ] out of thor meanwhile mule nursery
stuff out of thor meanwhile mjolnir's
going
it forms back together flies into her
hand she's like whoa
and then she's like whoa
i feel powerful
lightning crashes
another great alive
and then she's becomes thor and that's
it it's all part of her healing and that
makes her muscular
like a lightning crash i think i think
i agree with tommy because that rubble
that is left behind a mole near no one
else can lift so what if she is like
going on her like i'm just gonna go
travel the world a little bit and then
comes across it and it pieces back
together and goes into her hand sword in
the stone side
i think it
she feels like a pull almost like she
can't even she doesn't know what it is
following her to asgard she's dying she
gets the medical diagnosis which does
not have great results but it's very
accurate
she she goes to have her like last trip
around the world or whatever and she
feels compelled to go
to new asgard and when she gets there
mjolnir
reforms and is drawn to her because of
the connection to the ether the reality
stone which has been destroyed but still
is atomized out there in the universe i
like that okay second half of my theory
no
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding and
then and then valkyrie's there and she's
like oh you're jane foster i don't know
why she's australian in this one yeah
jane foster no why
oh no
you're jane foster
yes
i think we can all agree with you
but i mean the thrust of that is do we
think jane foster has been powered up
for a while like
more than a day or is it almost
happening in real time right did that
happen during the battle or has she been
there keeping asgard safe for a while
i think she's been in asgard because i
think all the clips that we're seeing
with her
and valkyrie i'm like not trying to be
mean but valkyrie is still like kind of
a standoffish person i don't think it's
going to be so quick for her and jane to
become close friends who just suggested
that in their theory okay well i'm just
saying are you waiting for me i'm right
i'm just saying i think that they've
been together they've been together for
a minute all right
and valkyrie wasn't blipped she lived
through
uh those five years yes
she was there yeah because they go and
see they see her and she's like yeah
thor's not handling it she had to kind
of take over you gotta remember valkyrie
had a bit of a drinking problem when she
was alright she was very depressed she
was in a dark place yeah she had a very
dark place this has given her new
meaning like having to be a king and a
leader yeah but maybe she's [ __ ] sick
of it she's she's wet sick freaking sick
okay really bad at all
if you don't want us to be restraining
ourselves so heavily you've got to
you've got to hit that tip jar yeah i
think they're doing a great job guys
thanks for being so generous so far you
know me i'm always thankful for the
super chats i think everybody does a
great job look at me real quick oh no
stingy stingy don't be mean we're 40
away okay reach down deep it's almost
christmas
[Music]
it's almost christmas in july
i think um there's a good chance that
yes that both this scene and
i don't there's so much that we don't
know we know like what the comics arc is
and they're certainly pulling some
things as tommy mentioned the toy
description seems like they're going to
pull some stuff from the comics arc but
the
exact way that all of this stuff happens
and comes together and the way taiko itt
and the marvel crew put it together we
don't know and it's gonna be really fun
to see
yeah uh speaking of fun to see oh thank
you uh abel nas
uh throwing in a big super chat i'll pay
for that bad word tom okay
thank you abel
a couple couple bucks left there and and
in the meantime we want to thank our
good friends at
athletic green yeah
we're sponsoring this show
um uh and they're with their signature
product eg1 yes this bad boy's got 75
high quality vitamins minerals
probiotics all the other good stuff you
need in your day tommy's a big fan of
simple greens i love ag-1 i love ag-1
guys i'm on the ag train athletic greens
not simple greens
they're very complex zac is going to do
this live
i'm doing a live a live niche i did a um
i did a one a one spoonful
mix yeah and and now i'm i'm going to
shake it up right on there now
this is risky this thing could explode
is that sealed properly it i i'm pretty
sure it's sealed okay uh if we ruin all
of our camera equipment by spritzing and
it looks great yes look at oh in real
time look at that
and i gotta say something they tell you
to do it on an empty stomach oh they do
and you know a lot of times you take
vitamins on an empty stomach you get a
little nauseous
you know something that's very nutrient
rich i take this on an empty stomach in
the morning i feel like a rocket ship
baby i want you to enjoy an empty
stomach because it like it soaks in yeah
you have to wear your belly and it gets
you like jazzed for the day you get your
body get your stomach ready to handle
whatever else you're gonna eat the rest
of the day all joking yeah no jokes
you know i love to joke but i do not
joke about ag-1 formula okay that's
right dead seriously we love it here we
appreciate athletic greens uh for
sponsoring uh the break room in the last
week we've all been drinking it feeling
good if you notice
certain bullies
of the cast a nice a glow
a youthful exuberance i mean i've been
telling you guys people have been coming
up to me and saying little boy where are
your pants
where are your parents and i'm like i'm
six one three hundred and seventy nine
my parents are dead from childbirth
i blew out of them
okay right now it's time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition you know
what you don't need a bunch of pills as
tommy was mentioning you just need an
option not for this anyway you just need
some awful imagery in your brain
a traumatic birth and a little athletic
greens uh right now if you order some
athletic greens they'll give you a free
one-year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase wow yes that's a great deal all
you have to go
is all you have to do is go to
break room the link is in this video's
description uh or athleticgreens.com
break room take ownership over your
health pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance uh
and you know what you know what time it
is tommy what's up hey
what did we talk about seeing morbius
well
what's coming up oh my gosh well you
know very critical of me on this show
but very rarely do you read the full
script that i painstakingly write every
day and that i gotta say
makes me feel
like dog [ __ ]
tommy swear we did unlock the swear jar
tommy okay yes thank you to everyone who
submitted super chats mr krabs soulgasm
on antorondo but do you want to know
what doesn't make me feel like dog poo
because we're out of the swear zone
mandatory fun
where's the graphic there it is oh yeah
you know this is the segment heard round
the world received so nice we play the
graphic twice
beautiful what a graphic a graphic that
has won over the hearts and minds so we
play it three times
too much the segment that keeps opening
up hearts and doors so we have to play
it in fours hit it again
we always keep it gucci to moochie on
mandatory fun baby and today
is no different
i've got my three best friends in the
whole wide world
that's very genuine have a little fun
with me and it ain't optional
it's mandatory yes unfortunately and
this keeps happening
i've got a doctor's appointment wow
so i can't be here for man you know this
is the time i know the show i know but
guess what doctors don't care when
you're as sick as i am you got to be
there every day why would you make the
appointment right after your hiatus
i was i'm not on hiatus i was attending
the beautiful wedding of my friends
garrett and darlene
and i gave it six years
my god i gotta go
so i'm gonna be here soon well i don't
know what we're gonna do
wow okay well he's just he just he plays
the graphic and then he bailed as long
as it's not tommy was very upset with me
earlier so i don't mind you replace this
uh we did get a super chat from freight
girl who asked on earth 838 what hero
has their own smash broadway musical
great girl you asked this on discord as
well and we did do it on on big question
which will come out later this week so
you will get an answer from me on that
one oh okay this is this would be the
equivalent of rogers the musical i gave
a very detailed answer about what i
think it is
will you just hint at it
it's not steve rogers i'll tell you that
much it's someone else who sacrificed
himself in the eighth week can i say
like quentin beck oh you think quentin
beck has the music i think they he gets
to
it's and it's like the
hang on you gossip hounds
how's it going it's going well
i'm harvey michael bechtold
and this is bmz
and soupy sauce what does bmz stand for
big man zack oh big man
no it stands for a bonus movie zeus oh
okay
i got my protein shake oh okay
it makes my heart ache
because i drink too much of it now
hot news on the street was that jar jar
binks
was originally going to play ugly sonic
and chip and dale yes
i saw that that was a real that really
is a real headline that's right so they
said we own the character jar jar binks
we don't own the character ugly sonic
let's pay out some money so we can deny
that jar jar binks exists they didn't
want to tarnish jar jar banks they want
jar jar binks to be a punch line now
that's the type of gas
that pleases the boss oh okay oh wow so
i'm hoping each one of you can hit me up
with a gossip story so juicy so lucy so
goosey
that we trend on twitter and we trend on
zwank which is the new app in sweden i
signed us up for swank yeah zwank it's a
gossip app in sweden who's got something
for me and and just to be clear are you
guys alright
harvey 11 ask
a figure is that is that right okay this
is bmz
oh sure you can't tell by my tight shirt
am i well well
i've been reaching out to my sources uh
oh wow you got a notebook
i did get some rumors i like you i i got
a i got a hot rumor for you apparently
you know top gun maverick is storming
the box office yeah it shot down doctor
strange like he was a rogue state
sending a jet out you know what i mean
if you've seen the movie you know what
that means uh apparently though that
wasn't the original script
uh the script that tom cruise really
wanted to make the movie focus on
was maverick taking his jet
flying into heaven oh
killing god
and bringing goose back down to a bit of
a gore the god butcher
yeah marvel stepped on his toes a little
bit but he wrote that script himself
now that's a rumor
that'll cure this tumor
oh you got it too man i love it now
there's some guys you didn't know
was this a bad medical diagnosis i got a
good i got a very accurate medical
diagnosis of some very bad news
my god
no a little birdie just tweeted tweet
tweeted in my ear
we'll be putting this up on this is a
zwank exclusive it's not going on the
bird app very swanky a twink exclusive
all right now this is a zwank exclusive
super chats of flying through the roof
right now
i heard a little birdie told me two of
my best gossip hounds went to the
theater on saturday night
okay so yeah these monsters in chat yes
as was teased earlier so on friday
i i made a statement this was not
pre-approved pre-planned i went i went
rogue like maverick against uh in top
gun maverick and i said that if we had
300 bucks in super chats i would go see
morbius for a second time at the theater
we did very quickly people really wanted
to punish me make me go see uh but then
there were enough people super chatting
saying actually i'll pay you not to see
it so i was like well if we hit 400 i
won't go yeah but then i was like but if
we hit 500 i'm back to going and you
know what everybody came through we hit
like 570 bucks so i went and saw uh
morbius at 10 p.m on saturday night at
the burbank amc 16. and
jessica though she didn't have to he
dragged me there she did not have to
tell me that i couldn't get paid for
this
show
he said he sent photos of jessica's cat
sleeping
if you ever want to see this cat wake up
wow you better come down okay well what
you're saying is
because of the chat you were in
you were out
you were back in you shook it all about
you went down to the amc you saw morbius
twice
and that made you feel real nice hey the
monkey pokey
so we did we did sit through uh morbius
for a second time we had joked
beforehand oh maybe we'll just go watch
the first ten minutes and sneak out we
watched the floor that's the full thing
90 minutes we even watched the trailers
before it yeah we've been watching
nicole kidman before are they still
showing old trailers no there's new
trains
we had nope we had um a new light year
one uh yeah the new it was and it was
the newer light year trailer yeah you
know this is what i told to nicholas
cage in 1994 when we were at the chateau
montmar yeah
heart attacks feel good in a place like
this
before then i don't know i'm on you've
heard the song old macdonald yeah i'm on
the fifth animal of hearts i have an
artificial goose
i've got a goose in here now is the song
old macdonald about arteries
yeah that's what they're saying old
macdonald had a farm and it saved his
life
every time his heart gave out they put
one in his chest
and an oink oink here here come here
everywhere
calm down before you have another heart
attack oh my god well i i wanted to say
that as as we were as i was walking up
to the to the theater for the 10 p.m
showing to morbius which by the way i
did throw it out anybody that wanted to
come watch it with us i don't think
anybody there were a surprising number
of people there was exactly 33 people
what's wrong with you people but i don't
think any of them were break room fans
or at least they didn't come up and say
hey maybe maybe they were keeping at low
key but as i was walking into the
theater okay
no no no no just drop an accidental
spoiler always morbius confirmed i wish
that would have made that movie that
much more fun but as i was walking up to
the theater there was a guy selling what
he said was officially licensed merch
out of his car no way
i bought
i did buy
a why sure wow zach i don't think that's
is that a banksy no no he said he said
he reappropriated a lab that had
previously been used to make counterfeit
money oh yeah but now it's making
officially licensed morbius
that's what i like most about science is
any laboratory can repurpose to do any
sort of science yeah that's yeah
yeah that's never gonna tell me anything
science can be done if morbid's taught
me anything it's about the phalanges in
your hand which i keep doing to people
i'm like i'm going to break your hands
oh that's right because he says as he's
breaking the guys in the lab what does
he say like oh you have this many bones
i keep calling them fallopian tubes
they're wanting to call themselves
that's what mine are actually they're
they're horse fellow people
i lost my fingers in a bowling accident
with jack nicholson
we were we were at the uh spare room
right on the third floor of the
roosevelt 1997. and i said as good as it
gets was about as bad as i'd ever seen
and he smashed my hand between a
14-pound ball in an australian guy's
face the actual dashboard cameraman is
not being able to hold up anymore
if the shot gets a little shaky it's
because dashiell's dying of light harvey
set your hands between these balls
yeah still the same confirmed they have
not changed the post-credits scene
that's great and then and uh sony didn't
change anything about this movie no it's
as is same yeah they really should they
should they should have it was a missed
opportunity i would have i would have
been especially down also we realized
they're only charging five bucks for
their favorite oh that's very distinct
that's kind of nice of them so i will
say
i'll tease i don't know that we're gonna
do the exact same thing this upcoming
friday morbius might not still be in
theaters but we're gonna do something
ridiculous on friday oh no okay
completely ridiculous that's not what
this show does
this show's about class yeah this show's
about dignity and this show's about law
and order yeah the series special
victims units yeah mariska hargitay
daughter of james mansfield
me and james manfield no i don't want to
know what
we were spotted at the amc 16. watch it
you kidding me swank is on fire right
now
we're going blergan that's viral do you
know the movie uh harvey harry do you
know the movie the nun
no i don't know the movie the nun the
scary movie i made a movie with a nun
once okay well that's not what i'm going
on check it out that's a different
heartbeat i think
so that's a different yeah there's a
different harvey joint so uh
the movie the nun the horror movie right
yeah so they were doing a casting call
an open casting call for the nun they
didn't think about oh we need her to
look more spooky we just need someone
that's played a nun before so they
reached out to whoopi goldberg no no no
they did they did they reached out to
what because
well this is the crazy part okay sorry
the crazy part they then reached out to
jay-z to dress her up as whoopi goldberg
jason dressed him up as well yeah the
dress come up as poppy goldberg as a nun
this is crazy because one night
at the w hotel in brooklyn i dress jay-z
up like whoopi goldberg for a little bit
of a role play yes yes and i said new
york where concrete jungles are broken
up by my thunderous yeah
it didn't work out do you like the scent
at the w new york you know every w has a
different smell yeah i do the one in new
york smells like uh smells like uh
regret smells like loss it smells like
people betting on the mex
instead of the yankees
was your interaction with jay-z is that
why solange uh kicked his ass in that
elevator
i guess you could say lemonade's about
me
milk milk is also about me and you go
around the corner and check out fudge
that's about me too
tommy eleven with the good hair over
here that's right
all right guys so i think uh we're
hearing from john's demanding that we
we're hearing from the boss that the
segment might need to end now
there are no winners in this segment
on bmz there are only gossip hounds so
stay tuned check out the website follow
us on zwink
yeah you guys have a good rest of your
day yeah wow okay bye
can i get my parking validated
i gotta go get a snakeheart put in my
chest
stop giving them animal parts uh so mr
krabs you had asked how more morbid
times two was that's that's how it is it
was actually a lot of fun mr krebs i
gotta say exactly i don't know that
jessica would agree i had a better time
watching it the second time i think i
came in with no expectations just there
to have a good time and it delivered
all right
jessica's never going to be the same
that's a good thing
uh
john attend had a super chat where he
asked would love to see skinny steve
become the sorcerer supreme in the next
what if series that's like an
interesting one uh
because we saw like
kenny steve become like the
i don't know what they call the not the
iron monger but like basically like iron
man
yeah yeah you have the suit yeah
yeah another what if with skinny steve
if you if it became like the source i
like that unsuper soldier and steve yeah
you will yeah yeah that's great he'd be
a good sorcerer
okay
[Music]
let's run through a couple other
headlines i heard tommy's uh doctor's
appointment might be wrapping up
sometimes in in an exclusive interview
uh with the direct uh miss marvel and
producer sana amanot uh apologies i'm oh
you're somebody tell me you missed uh
you missed a really fun uh mandatory fun
i did yeah
damn it
well sorry guys that was a quick
doctor's appointment though that's oh i
got some bad news they're going to try
and put a goose heart in me
don't say one of my hearts wow of all
the animals i i wouldn't think a goose
would be that compatible with evidently
my heart is so badly damaged any goose
will do
hopefully it turns into a swan right
is that how that works
all right so that our writer producer on
miss marvel uh addressed um
about kamala's origin and like where it
falls
uh where the story of miss marvel kind
of falls on the mcu timeline
and uh she had this to say i feel like
it's one to two years something like
that after end game uh i don't actually
know for sure but we do have that in our
timeline so that's kind of interesting a
few years after in game that's also when
um
[Music]
uh is that when we're assuming kind of
hawkeye and those things are taking yeah
hawkeye kind of takes place the same
time as spider-man no way home right we
saw uh rockefeller plaza has the
christmas tree that's 2024 leading into
2025. so we assume if we keep moving
forward uh uh multiverse of madness that
happens in 2025 because doctor strange
doesn't know anything about spider-man
he doesn't know how his webs work or
anything he's that's all been white from
his memory so we're probably in 2025
which would be two years after
the blip uh which was in 2023 so that
all makes sense and they're we seem to
be catching up moving forward they're
still a couple years ahead of us in real
time but we're
slowly catching up i guess yeah and
they're i don't think they want to jump
ahead anytime soon again uh and i'm
hoping like she-hulk and everything
keeps moving forward yeah yeah and not
kind of
seeing different parts of the same time
period or something like that yeah um
we've also learned this is kind of just
a silly fun fact that miss marvel's
rating has increased from a tvpg to a tv
14.
yeah
uh and just for folks that don't know
right it goes tvpg tv 14
mature audiences i believe and that's
supposed to be for 17 and up is the one
above so this one is cool for people uh
14 and up presumably um previous uh
marvel disney plus shows have mostly
been tv 14 but a few of them have like
differed from episode to episode
depending on the kind of i think and i
also think that in general if my
understanding of the rank rating systems
for tv goes it's a little similar to
movies where they're not saying
that you like 14 is the age in which you
can handle this they're saying that if
your kids are under 14 you should watch
it with them so that they you can if
they have questions they're not just
guessing as to why things like you know
violent things are happening that way
you can kind of contextualize oh this is
a you know a powered individual doing
something that's a it's a really mature
way to look at it well i'm actually a
pretty mature guy i don't know who keeps
subbing in for me
but
yeah
uh below the line recently i spoke to
hawkeye's two composers uh christophe
beck and michael perez-gevis i think i'm
saying those right uh who they had an
interesting quote just in talking about
their process of making um the music for
hawkeye they mentioned that they had
originally made a score that was a lot
darker to match a much darker tone for
the series but then as the series kind
of became lighter in tone they had to
redo
their score
which is an interesting thing right like
it was originally maybe going to explore
more of kind of hawkeye's trauma coming
out of all the events of end game and
things like that dealing with his
hearing loss that's interesting yeah and
then when it kind of shifted to be maybe
a little bit more of a k bishop story
and kind of be this buddy yeah um you
know cop kind of a
a thing that that shifted the tone and
the soundtrack and this was like the
score
not the soundtrack necessarily because
i'm wondering if it initially it wasn't
even set at christmas time and that's
something that came later well if you go
through
i had the luxury of reading this whole
article whereas you know others are just
only reading the headlines now they talk
about how they had to incorporate the
christmas music in and how like well
yeah then we had to kind of make new
music that were
plays off of existing christmas songs
and now that kind of made it both easier
and more complicated like you know
easier to make maybe make the songs but
more complicated to figure out which
songs to use
to still set a tone for an action series
and then
guys whatever i burned myself off
the doctor
was really wow i'm that thor on that
source area that didn't go over
in an interview with screen rant emily
swallow who plays the armorer on the
mandalorian that's one of my favorite
characters never seen her face on the
show sorry sorry celebration beautiful
woman not that that matters of course
but you know she's kind of a waste of an
attractive actor isn't it they could put
a real ugo under the helmet yeah
the redemptions that will be coming in
the future will be like teamed up and i
wanted to be
well aware
because they are already at negative
five
between these tapes yeah
oh my god okay he's doing [ __ ]
from goonies
okay that's a what if i'd like to see um
but uh again it's a great character we
haven't seen a lot of but that um that
character the armored character's gonna
be playing a bigger role in season three
yes now tommy you're at star wars
celebration yes again you mentioned you
saw this actress in person she was there
on the panel and you got to see a little
bit of footage yes they should they
showed two different teasers well
they sort of teased her thursday and
then they showed another teaser saturday
that was
uh longer and she is in several scenes
in just the teaser trailer including
like a lot more active scenes like you
know a lot of times we just see her kind
of
see how is that hiding yeah yes but i
mean like you know even when she's like
you know forging things like she's just
kind of standing there extolling wisdom
i i don't want to spoil it for people
but she gets active let's just say
there's some fighting scenes oh yeah so
we saw her handle herself with their
weapons against the dark saber yeah
right good powerful stuff hammer
that's great yeah sorry not to
this cough is because i was crying
um the the people in the in the polls
yes they said
would you prefer jar jar over ugly sonic
and chip and dale and a lot said yes oh
wow there's a pretty close election
there actually
i thought it was an uh people are ready
for the jar jar that sounds like we
first of all we want darth jar jar we
want to see jar jar go yeah that's my
friend give away the senate my friend
dylan would say jar jar is the key a
quote from
george lucas jar jar
uh we got a couple other polls that
thank you jessica for reminding us to uh
check in with those um
67
of you saying you're going to see thor 4
on opening night as opposed to waiting
till
saturday afternoon
sunday uh midday whatever um that's a
pretty strong number um also okay so we
were talking about this right before the
show
this we don't know for sure the times
but we think
tomorrow night at midnight
or you know into early wednesday for us
on the west coast yes early wednesday
morning for most folks we are getting
both obi-wan episode
four four thank you and miss marvel
episode one both dropping the same night
so how do you prioritize which do you
watch first assuming they're both
dropping the same time which we think
they are and we've got um
57 saying they're watching obi-wan first
uh 38 saying miss marvel 4 saying
neither you for our trolls
maybe
they're not gonna watch them on
wednesday the question asks for someone
else that's true
and you know what maybe trolls maybe
some people are not star wars or
or marvel fans but they still like
watching this show
maybe they're jessica fans maybe they're
brandon fans maybe they're zach fans
maybe they're tommy fans maybe they're
daschle fans guys if you want to watch
this show just for the fun banter and
the drinks i get it
but if you're going to do that pay up
okay this ain't free i'm wondering if
disney because they surprised us by
dropping obi-wan kenobi early thank you
so much for dropping it yeah
you said it midnight yeah but that was
also they had star wars celebration
going on they had a lot of fans there so
i'm one they might drop miss marvel
early to be like hey we got a new show
check it out i don't know it'll be
interesting to see if they drop them
both at the same time we of course would
love it if they spread those out on
different nights
yes someone said painter said how was
matt smith's dancing and this is a scene
that me and zach looked each other in
the eyes in this dark theater to be like
i wish he didn't do this this is really
hard
just as cringy maybe more cringy as ever
we're talking about oh sorry
second viewing of that scene where uh
lucian aka um
milo right um the poor character is
negged from childhood yeah no wonder he
turns up saying i would have ate him too
if i could have tried to eight just
straight vampire just eat strangers
individuals
allison becker 94 points b adam trailer
drops in two days talk about it please
brian adams
yeah putting out new music
that's crazy no matter what year it is
it's separate
the black adam trailer is coming out uh
wednesday it's gonna be a busy day yeah
a lot to talk about but we will talk
about it because most of us don't know
much about black adam yeah except uh
jessica's been reading the comics she
knows a ton about it he's fine and i'm
very interested to see what this movie
is going to be all about
i don't know i was really impressed with
shazam this is yes shazam reverse i
believe
uh which is technically part of the dceu
though it seems like it wants to be like
we're gonna we might have our own thing
yeah and we'll see if they make any
attempts we'll see if there's a wonder
woman cameo in this or something like
that we don't know um but i'd love to
see what they're wrong i want to hop
around a little bit uh we're going to
skip what we're going to talk about next
because i want to be sure to get to this
jessica you have a little bit of an
inside scoop you brought up something
earlier today that i want to try oh you
don't want to talk about it okay okay
maybe tomorrow well we can yeah we can
talk about
okay allegedly allegedly you guys i'm on
a bunch of weird servers to figure out
when she's on the dark world i'm on the
dark web trying to find out what marvel
tickets go on safe what's the dark web
we'll get into it later we'll talk about
it offline but you guys the tickets if
you have an amc pass or if you're an amc
person um this is compared to fandango
or whatever the tickets for thor love
and thunder allegedly will go on sale
tomorrow morning um just like multiverse
and madness it went on sale like six a.m
a month from the the day the movie comes
out about 30 days out right yeah but
we're fighting in our little server
because there's news now that they're
pushing it to june 16th oh wow i'm going
just you guys know dang well i'm gonna
still wake up at 5 00 a.m and just be
prepared because those tickets go out so
quick and i want a normal seat when i
saw spider-man no way home far far left
dude and i was third row third row from
the front it's you can't even see it
they're gonna have multiple screens but
you want like a dolby i do one well even
then sometimes they sell out still still
they sell out so quickly before eleven
thunderstorms just go with three am when
they're not even open well i need i
wanna see it before twitter sees it
so that's why you guys you heard it here
first jessica is confirming 6am tomorrow
they will definitely be on sale hit her
up at luluclemens on twitter if they are
not on sale directly at six you can yell
at me but i will also be awake and feel
your pain science winkers on zwink if
she's wrong yeah also hit us up on his
way where i think we're we're not
flergling anymore
no we're not on twitch we're on swank
and please be
don't careful these people to the wrong
uh social media i'm trying to build our
following here guys
folks especially our break room uh
viewers we appreciate all of you we
don't know if this is going to turn out
to be true but even if there's a
possibility we want to give them the
inside school and you know what jessica
if you miss out on a ticket
wouldn't you feel a little bit better
knowing that at least you missed out to
an awesome break room fan who jumped on
it someone like john ayton who said
would love to see skinny steve become so
you already read that yeah someone like
anto rondon that says love you guys
favorite mcu couple go bills favorite
mcu couple icarus in the sun baby
oh
dang heartless murderous foul
my favorite couple is uh uh
probably tony and helper hmm whoa
oh i i didn't that's not how i thought
that was gonna end no helper the robot
that's what i thought that's why i was
like you mean pepper
and poor helper's still alive just
living in an awkward apartment yeah
looking for tony tony
my favorite is wanda and vision yeah
that's so strong it's always gonna be
bad and it's they're an unusual couple i
think i i've mine's actually a tie it's
black widow and gamora and the ground
too
it's so vicious
the ground
it's a three-way um well you know what
we have some we were gonna drop some
kind of interesting warner brothers dc
conversation but maybe we'll push that
until tomorrow
we had too much to get through today um
i think that's a really good
conversation i don't want to cut it
short i agree there was some great news
that kind of came out over the weekend
about like kind of the future
restructuring of warner brothers what
that's going to mean for dc the dc eu
going forward i think we'll have a good
chat about that tomorrow we appreciate
everybody that was there with us uh joe
79 am
getting another go bills in there
hey
what if on friday they get to choose the
movie we see
that'd be fun i got a free weekend guys
go ahead send me a feeder yes we're
still figuring out all we know is
friday's gonna get nuts okay that's
that's a guarantee um and the the chat
redemptions are gonna be wild okay so
stick around we appreciate you for
watching on the monday we hope you have
a great rest of your week hopefully uh
your monday was a good one your weekend
was restful and tuesday through friday
will be uh
positive and productive for you
absolutely thank you so much for
watching thank you to the three of you
for uh joining me
thanks for having me i'm so sorry that i
i couldn't be here for mando fun but uh
okay hopefully tomorrow i could be here
and uh i hope whoever filled in
was under control well i think they like
that mike put in a super chat hopefully
that dmz character comes i think i think
i meant dmz
this is a dmz though right he loves the
demolition
yeah
i hope you're feeling better out there
well you know what i think we just snuck
a second swear jar in under the wire wow
okay i feel like we got so close to a
second one and uh somebody just threw in
uh a twenty dollar super chat so i feel
like we owe it to him should we do like
a team like yes
but first i wanna say alex zavala it was
our pleasure to get you through it buddy
and we're going to this swear goes out
to you what are we swearing um or an
oath or uh what word are we doing
let's say
on the count of three [ __ ] ass yeah
yeah great not but that's not about you
alex you're not a [ __ ] ass we're saying
this to your enemies yes with joy ready
[Music]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
you